رجح مدير اداره شرق الاوسط واسيا الوسطى
لصندوق النقد الدولي ان يتباطا نمو الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا هذا العام جراء عده عوامل
من بينها السياسات المتشدده لاستعاده
استقرار الاقتصاد الكليه وقال المسؤول
الدولي ان نسبه التواطئ ستبلغ ثلاث نقاط
وعنصر النقطه في المئه نزولا من خمس نقاط
وثلاثه العام الماضي كما ستسجل البلدان
ذات الدخل المنخفض في المنطقه نموا لا
يتخطى نقطه مئويه وثلاثه اعشار في المئه
هذا العام بسبب ارتفاع اسعار السلع
الاوليه وعدم استقرار الاقتصاد العالمي
وبفضل ارتفاع اسعار النفط كشف مسؤول صندوق
النقد ان السعوديه حققت نموا في الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي بلغ 8.17 اعشار في المئه
خلال العام الماضي وهي اعلى نسبه بين دول
مجموعه العشرين